[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 31 octobre
bienvenue dans le journal de tv 60 18 26
minutes d'actualité locale voici les
titres de cette édition
elle s'est installée cet été dans la
zone industrielle de coignières
l'entreprise car watts transforme des
véhicules thermiques industriels et de
transport en électrique
la société travaille actuellement sur
deux grands projets notamment en
tanzanie le week-end de la toussaint
débutent ce soir l'occasion d'aller
rendre hommage à ces défunts et pour
ceux qui ne pourront pas se rendre dans
les cimetières des sociétés spécialisées
entretiennent les sépultures reportage à
maurepas
et puis le portrait de la semaine aura
un accent américain la chef cybèle
réalise des plats gastronomiques et
locavore ces produits proviennent de son
potager en permaculture un coin de terre
installé à gambais et puis à suivre
aussi à tout à l'heure les jeunes
engagés pour le climat avec une antenne
de youth for climate qui sait est
ouverte à saint quentin en yvelines
cette information pour débuter le
suppléant de nadia est la députée lrm de
la 11e circonscription des yvelines
impliqué dans un trafic de drogue entre
le maroc et la france moussa war où ça a
été mise en examen pour importation
transport et détention de produits
stupéfiants en bande organisée ainsi
qu'association de malfaiteurs à l'homme
de 33 ans a été remise en liberté et
placé sous contrôle judiciaire et le
compte est ce l'effet pour le moment et
a même déposé plusieurs plaintes pour
diffamation à ce sujet en réaction nadia
affirmé être surprise par cette affaire
elle le dit avoir plus aucun contact
avec lui depuis plusieurs mois en raison
de désaccords politiques mais croit
cependant en la présomption d'innocence
on vous en a parlé hier le projet de
fusion entre fiat chrysler qui est
installé à trappes en france et psa qui
discute donc d'une potentielle fusion
l'ambition c'est de devenir le quatrième
groupe mondial automobile avec plus de 8
millions de véhicules vendus chaque
année capitale divisée à parts égales le
siège aux pays-bas un protocole d'accord
doit être conclue d'ici les prochaines
années ps a également implanté dans les
yvelines avec deux centres techniques à
vélizy et carrières sous poissy est une
usine à poissy qui compte 3600 salariés
non loin des locaux de fiat chrysler
france à trappes l'entrepôt de
logistique de kuehne et nagel une
vingtaine d'employés de ce groupe
spécialisé dans le service de stockage
de pièces de rechange de camions et
autobus étaient en grève aujourd'hui
elle est salariée mobiliser dénonce de
mauvaises conditions de travail mais
aussi des salaires qui n'auraient pas
évolué depuis plusieurs années les
propos sont recueillis sur place par
aurélie ans
depuis dix ans on a des augmentations
qui sont en dessous de l'inflation donc
le calcul est simple que ça veut dire
que le pouvoir d'achat il diminue il
faut savoir dans cette entreprise qui
appartient à un grand groupe
international qui font des milliards de
bénéfices quoi alors n'a pas de prime
d'intéressement n'a pas de prime de
participation n'est pas typhi ce qu'on
va dire on est là on veut juste que se
montrer comme quoi on est mécontent et
qui qui au moins qu'on ait une
discussion sérieuse avec les syndicats
afin que le personnel soit récompensé à
sa juste valeur
les salariés prévoient d'autres journées
de mobilisation s'ils ne sont pas
entendus pas de commentaire du côté de
la direction le service communication
indique que des discussions sont en
cours
c'est une nouvelle entreprise installée
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines car watts est arrivé à
coignières en juillet dernier son
activité transformer des véhicules
thermiques en véhicules électriques une
société en contrats avec des entreprises
est de safari en tanzanie aussi le
groupe air france les détails avec
nicolas landry sur ce véhicule
on a retiré le moteur thermique c'est la
spécialité de l'entreprise car watts
remplacer le moteur thermique par un
système électrique une activité sur des
véhicules lourds comme sur cette voiture
de safari un moteur électrique donc
cette fois ci c'est un vraiment
permanent avec son contrôleur moteur et
tous les auxiliaires nécessaires
électrification d'un véhicule pour
alimenter ce moteur électrique on a
besoin d'une batterie donc là je vous
présente une batterie issus de seconde
vie une batterie reconfigurer ce projet
véhicule électrique pour safari atteint
déjà plusieurs dizaines de commandes à
venir une phase d'industrialisation en
collaboration avec des entreprises en
tanzanie
il ya déjà 4 kills d'électrification
quiche en partie sur place qui viennent
d arriver ils viennent d dédouaner nos
équipes techniques vont aller sur place
pour les mettre en oeuvre à partir de
novembre
né en 2014 car wattré utilisent des
batteries son principal fournisseur le
groupe renault avec des systèmes
électriques de véhicules zoé et kangoo
en juillet 2019 elle décide de
s'installer à saint quentin en yvelines
nous paraît pertinent d'aller dans ce
que j'appellerais l'automotive valais
les compétences on les trouve localement
en plus des compétences humaines issues
il ya tout un tissu de petites sociétés
de la connectique de la mécanique de la
transformation qui pour nous est
essentielle autre type de production
avec comme clients le groupe air france
l'équipement des véhicules présents sur
les pistes d'aéroports comme les tapis
pour mettre les bagages dans les avions
à partir de batteries kangoo on part
d'une batterie renault kangoo deuxième
vie qu'on va démonter pour pouvoir
récupérer une partie donc des modules la
société comptera douze salariés à la fin
de l'année son chiffre d'affaires va
passer de 20000 euros fin 2010 8 à
500000 euros fin 2010 9
le mouvement organise des agrève
scolaire en réponse à l'appel de great
attenberg les jeunes sont engagées pour
la défense de la planète au travers de
youth for climate initiative mondiale
qui se décline à saint quentin en
yvelines où un comité local a été lancée
cette année pour en parler
sacha bourguet bonsoir ça vous avez 17
ans vous êtes le cofondateur de ce
comité local de youth for climate
pourquoi le lancer à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines austère signé
avec des amis pour la marche pour le
climat le 25 mai marche mondiale pour le
climat est une de nos amies justement
faisait partie du mouvement il sort
climate nationale elle été graphiste
pour ce mouvement et on s'est dit que ce
serait bien à notre échelle d'agir est
pour ca de créer un groupe local sur
saint-quentin puisqu'il y en avait pas
encore donc l'idée a émergé de cette
date le 25 mai dernier cette grève
mondiale pour pour le climat ça c'est
une date tournant pour lui c'est vrai
c'est la date de la création est
aujourd'hui qui composent qui composent
ce comité local vous êtes lycéen ce que
ce sont essentiellement des lycéens est
ce qu'il ya des étudiants d'université
est ce que c'est un peu tout ça
finalement on est une quarantaine de
jeunes entre 14 et 25 ans d'accord que
c'est assez élargie mais savait que la
majorité sont soit
enfin collèges soient lycéens soit le
début des études donc également des
collégiens on peut s'engager très tôt
dans ce 4e 3e on est une quarantaine
donc dans une vingtaine de vraiment
actif et on disait donc d'être
fondatrice le 25 mai c'est ça ou émerger
cette idée de créer le comité local
c'est là bas on a on est quelques scouts
dans le groupe et donc en étant scouts
on a toujours été assez sensibilisés à
la cause
on est proche de la nature la l'habitude
de d'essayer de limiter notre
consommation
mais on enfin on se rend compte quand
même que c'est de plus en plus
médiatisées l'urgence climatique et du
coup ça nous a paru vraiment important
d'agir à notre échelle à la marque du 25
on a rencontré des gens on a pu discuter
des gens partager nos expériences et ça
permet de sensibiliser et on a été
nous-mêmes sensibilisés lors de cette
marche de voir l'engagement de tant de
personnes a été presque miel et me
semble dit pourquoi justement les jeunes
doivent se saisir de ces sujets d'après
vous ceci j'ai ce sujet du climat je
pense que absolument tout le monde doit
faire des efforts
à ce sujet puisque d'ici une trentaine
d'années il peut y avoir des
répercussions très graves même en europe
où les généralement ce soir à ses
protégés et donc tout le monde doit agir
y compris les jeunes pas seulement les
adultes sous prétexte que en est mineur
et qu'on a moins de responsabilités on
ne peut pas ne pas agir et donc du coup
en étant jeune
on est aussi dynamique on est plongée
dans les études et dans l'apprentissage
du comptage du rosé pour votre futur
c'est ça parce que nous on va toucher
directement mais même les adultes
finalement à ce moment-là tout
de se mobiliser à nîmes de se mobiliser
voilà et compris les jeunes et vous
disiez au travers de votre engagement
chez les scouts c'est une thématique
cette défense de voilà de
l'environnement de la planète c'est une
thématique qui vous est cher c'est ça ça
vous vient depuis très jeune beaucoup de
valeur oui son communiqué au sein des
scouts la solidarité et la bienveillance
et aussi le respect de la nature et
finalement au delà de la nature en elle
même c'est l'humanité qu'on protège en
luttant contre le réchauffement
climatique puisque il ya enfin pour
donner quelques chiffres par exemple il
y à une zone qui est actuellement invité
par 4,5 millions de chinois qui sera
potentiellement inhabitables à cause de
sécheresse
d'ici une cinquantaine d'années si le
réchauffement climatique n'est pas si on
met en place des normes actions pour
réduire nos émissions carbone en afrique
également les récoltes vont être divisés
par deux d'ici 2050 et la population
aura été multipliée par deux et ça peut
entraîner des vagues de migrations
climatiques seulement énorme de
centaines de millions de personnes
il ya une urgence à agir vous je crois
que vous êtes éco-délégués c'est ça dans
votre lycée à montigny le bretonneux
expliquez-nous un peu ce qu'ils sont ce
que sont vos missions
puis sort maintenant dans beaucoup de
lycées il ya déjà le
les directions qui met en place un
système d'éco délégation où dans chaque
classe il ya entre une et trois
personnes qui sont éco délégués et donc
qu'ils peuvent monter des projets dans
leur lycée pour le climat nous par
exemple faire des composts essayé
d'organiser des jours sans viande
le tri dans les classes j'ai beaucoup
dit c'est qu'ils font mais pas tous dans
le mien pas encore annoncé ses petites
actions au sein d'un lycée qui peuvent
aussi servir et s'étendre un plus grand
cercle
finalement mais surtout dans mon lycée y
avait pas par exemple déco délégation
bien en place à la base et il faut pas
hésiter à les voir la directrice est lui
dire qu'on veut mettre en place des
projets pour le climat ensuite à
chercher nous mêmes des éco délégués
dans les classes une fois que le conseil
est monté les directions générales nous
suit et nous nous aident dans nos
projets et si on revient à l'antenne
locale donc de youth for climate quel
est le projet qu'est lequel projet vous
allez développer là dans les prochains
mois entertainment ont fait
déclinologues donc du ramassage de
déchets est aussi l'intervention dans
les écoles on va aller dans les écoles
primaires de montigny et je pense que la
sensibilisation c'est vraiment un point
extrêmement important pour lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique puisque
finalement pour que des réformes très
important de ceux mis en place même par
le gouvernement il faut que les gens
soient prêts à changer leurs modes de
vie et pour ça c'est la sensibilisation
qui est un présent faire dans les écoles
une prochaine date de réunion que sur
laquelle vous vouliez communiqué il y
avait le 9 novembre
on se retrouve à 15h15 à la gare pour
planifier l'année par les deux projets
et accueillir toute nouvelle personne
dans le groupe on retrouve toutes les
informations sur votre page facebook qui
s'est affiché à plusieurs reprises
durant cet entretien merci sacha
bourgade est repassé en plateau merci
d'avoir invité je rappelle que vous êtes
le co fondateur de l'antenne locale
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de la youth
for et climate un mot de santé pour
apporter un suivi médical personnalisé à
leurs patients l'hôpital privé de
l'ouest parisien à trappes propose des
soins de support ils permettent aux
malades de cancers de discuter avec des
professionnels de santé ces soins sont
dispensés en début de prise en charge
pendant les traitements et aussi après
rencontre avec des diététicienne
nutritionniste des psychologues et des
kinésithérapeutes des spécialistes qui
sont à votre disposition
éditions pour pouvoir vous aider face à
la lutte contre la pathologie les
interviews au micro de manon varaldo les
soins de support ce sont l'ensemble des
soins mais traitement que l'ombre que
l'on peut proposer à des patients
cancéreux ou des patients atteints de
maladie particulièrement grave
à côté des traitements spécifiques
qu'elles sont la chimiothérapie des
rayons la chirurgie et c'est donc cette
soins de supports permettent
pendant toute la durée de la prise en
charge du patient de lui apporter une
aide
j'interviens pour tout ce qui concerne
l'alimentation des patients donc
l'apport des aliments et aussi les
apports hydriques
quelle que soit la problématique ça peut
être une problématique avant opération
donc pour faire un bilan préopératoire
ça peut être une problématique de
réalimentation après opération où ça
peut être des effets secondaires des
traitements de chimiothérapie ou
d'hormonothérapie aujourd'hui on sait
que la part psychologique dans la prise
en charge et l'accompagnement du cancer
est vraiment importante pouvoir mettre
des mots sur ce qu'on ressent sur ce
qu'on vit diminuer les angoisses mais
aussi essayer de limiter les affects
dépressif c'est vraiment une part
majeure
ce soir c'est le début du week end
prolongé de la toussaint et bison futé
voit rouge dans le sens des départs dans
les yvelines et dans toute l'île de
france ce jeudi cela s'annonce également
difficile sur les rails à partir de
demain de vendredi à dimanche inclus le
trafic du rer c est interrompue aucun
train ne circulera entre les gares de
saint quentin en yvelines et des
invalides perturbations en raison et des
travaux de mise en accessibilité qui
sont effectués en garde versailles rive
gauche
un service de bus de substitution sera
mis en place à partir de la gare de
saint-quentin avec une desserte des
gares intermédiaires et en cette période
de jours fériés pas toujours facile de
se rendre au cimetière pour entretenir
la tombe d'un proche des sociétés se
développe au travers à travers la france
pour le faire à votre place des
interventions qui se déroule également
dans les yvelines reportage de mélanie
poké à maurepas une petite photo pour
replacer à l'identique pendant la
demi-heure qui va suivre flavien va
prendre soin de cette sépulture au
cimetière de mort
pas ici reposent les proches d'une
famille francilienne cette sépulture que
ça fait à peu près trois ans qu'on
intervient sur ce cimetière ne meurent
pas visage et ça c'est une famille qui
fait appel à nos services tous les mois
donc vous passerons tous les mois
entretenir fleurir la sépulture en
fonction des fleurs qu'ils ont souhaité
que l'on dispose sur la sépulture avec
un associé ils ont fondé une société
spécialisée en 2008 basées dans les
bouches du rhône une demande des clients
liés à l'éloignement des familles ou de
descendants âgées
on a le sentiment que les familles ont
de plus en plus besoin de préserver la
mémoire
de leurs proches disparus internet il ya
beaucoup pour cela puisque aujourd'hui
effectivement beaucoup plus facile et
j'ai envie de dire que sociologiquement
les gens sont plus aptes à acheter des
prestations de services à distance
l'entreprise pratique environ dix mille
interventions par an l'entretien d'une
sépulture est obligatoire et une
concession abandonné peut être prise par
la mairie
les chefs hélène darroze et philippe
etchebest à versailles le programme
culinaire top chef a installé ses
caméras hier au domaine de madame
elisabeth l'émission sera diffusée
courant avril les six candidats sur
place ont dû plancher sur le thème des
pâtes le domaine de madame elisabeth où
sont produits chaque année 2,5 tonnes de
légumes grâce à son potager elle utilise
justement son potager en permaculture
depuis six ans à la chef cybèle ravi les
papilles à boulogne billancourt pour
aller encore plus loin dans sa démarche
locavore au plus proche de la nature
elle et son mari se sont installés à
gambais une rencontre signée patrick
jacques de dixmude et mme anne marie
lehn iapichino chaque fois qu'elle en a
besoin
cybèle enfile ses bottes et pas récolter
ces denrées directement au potager cacf
rien autres comme ça c'est vraiment il
ya l'odeur de la terre il ya l'odeur de
la carotte qui dégage quand on les
enlève ce jardin a une particularité il
est entièrement en permaculture
une production qui profitent des
ressources de la nature et se passe
complètement de produits chimiques comme
avec cette petite mare implanté au
milieu pour attirer les grenouilles
elles sont venues tout ça tout seul et
ce qu'elles font balade dans le potager
animatrice id naturel en fait mais en
rythme avec ma nature depuis un an la
cheffe de cuisine et son mari se sont
lancés dans cette aventure
les premières récoltes ont été réalisés
durant l'été et le domaine s'est ouvert
à la clientèle en septembre moi j'avais
un potager à côté
innobio entre guillemets on a fait face
à biot l'époque c'était juste normal
c'était naturel c'est comme ça que je
continue et ça c'est une étape encore
qui va encore plus loin
faut donner du plaisir à nous et surtout
le client maison qu'ils consomment et
qui participe sorte avec nous cette
aventure un projet d'abord imaginé sur
le toit de leur restaurant à boulogne
billancourt mais trop difficile à
réaliser
ils se sont alors mis en quête d'un
lopin de terre dans la campagne
francilienne et sont finalement tombés
amoureux du domaine les bruyères à
gambais plus qu'un potager
ils ont installé un restaurant
gastronomique la cuisine c'est comme le
potager c'est une cuisine vivante rien
déjà qu'avec à la vue c'est une cuisine
qui visaient des plaques de vie et après
quand on goûte ses plats et bien c'est
une cuisine qui apporte différentes
saveurs tout en gardant en fait le
produit en bouche en cuisine je suis
aussi dans un engagement anti gaspillage
donc par exemple je prends des petites
carottes vous allez faire rôtir des plus
grosses carottes j'ai fait en juin et
ensuite j'ai réduit je vais faire une
petite vinaigrette sac à main c'est un
peu au sirop peu pour accompagner cette
carotte rôti une ricotta maison et un
oignon roses du jardin
chaque élément de la carotte et
retravailler avec des fanes de carottes
le fait un petit piste où même les
fleurs de la carotte servent pour la
décoration accompagné de capucine pour
ajouter un goût poivré
le but c'est d'avoir une harmonie dans
l'assiette avoir différentes textures
défend goût
pourquoi on s'ennuie pas et c'est comme
une petite voyage avec tous les
différents éléments et pour partager
leur havre de paix jusqu'au bout il
propose cinq chambres d'hôtes qui
préfère nommer chambre de campagne dont
chacune porte un nom d'arbre histoire de
dormir dans un boulot et déguster les
plats de cybèle directement issu du
jardin cette exploitation à des élevages
de vaches et de moutons pendant toutes
les vacances la firme de grignon
organisait des olives forme days visite
des lieux avec à la fin un jeu de
dégustation de yaourt produits sur place
nicolas landry a suivi la balade
ils ont choisi la ferme de grignon pour
une sortie pendant les vacances
d'automne plusieurs visiteurs venus en
famille à la découverte des conditions
de vie des vaches de l'exploitation
notamment les 40 kg de nourriture donnée
à chaque bête par jour prim'holstein
pour la petite histoire la holstein est
une région donc situe entre l'allemagne
et la hollande et on les appelle les
prim'holstein
parce que ce sont les premières vaches à
avoir été exportées vers l'étranger
aujourd'hui la prim'holstein c'est
l'arrêt ce qu'on rencontre le plus
souvent dans le monde parce que c'est
celle qui produit le plus de lait
contrairement à ce qu'on croit à une
vache ne boit que de l'eau
elle ne boit pas de lait d'accord ni de
jus d'orange
on est d'accord la rencontre avec les
animaux se poursuit avec les veaux
élevés séparés de leur mère pour
consommer du lait en bonne quantité
il ya aussi la bergerie avec des brebis
et leurs petits agneaux qui détestent
auprès de sa mère et et quand je me suis
approché ici en fille c'est très mignon
direction ensuite la laiterie le lieu où
le lait est transformé en yaourts crème
fraîche ou mises en briques
on peut donc pas entrer à l'intérieur
pour des raisons d'hygiène alors l'idée
c'est vraiment de réussir à reconstituer
toutes les étapes de l'air ball est
finalement et de l'herbe aux produits
laitiers qu'en définitive donc essayer
de comprendre un peu tout ce qui se
passe avant le d'abord le yaourt servi
sur la table directement après la visite
de la ferme place à un jeux sensoriels
le but déguster et deviner les saveurs
et le parfum des yaourts produits à la
ferme acides c'est comme le site pour
c'est comme le citron parce que là ça
serait comme les sites
moi j'irai
l'odeur aller forte le goût et sucre et
la cannelle mais après pas grand chose
la ferme est ouverte au public tous les
jours pour des visites libres durant
toute l'année et même si les vacances de
la toussaint sont quasiment terminées il
reste encore un week-end prolongé
bonsoir mélanie poker bon ça vous venez
en plateau pour vos idées de sorties
loisirs du week-end et et vous nous
proposer cette semaine un rendez-vous
royal et oui grégory ses week-ends c'est
le retour de la cour royale la course
pédestre organisée par la commune de
fontenay le fleury avec versailles grand
parc cette année plus de 500
participants sont attendus à 10 heures
sur la ligne de départ qui se trouvait
là la pièce d'eau des suisses à
versailles alors pourquoi ne pas vous
glisser parmi les 600 spectateurs le
long du parcours
quelques précisions avec l'adjoint au
maire qui était l'invité de michael elle
ni d'euros lundi 28 octobre et on
traverse la plaine de versailles le parc
du château de versailles pour arriver
dans la commune de fontaines fleuries
il ya de petites complications mais
c'est beaucoup plus de plat et avec ce
qu on dit dans le jargon décorer un
petit casse pattes comment à la fin de
course pour leur faire voir que voilà
ces données c'est pas non plus une
partie de plaisir
alors deux épreuves au programme un 10
km une course nature de 20km aussi une
randonnée de marche nordique est une
course pour enfants à sur une distance
de deux kilomètres alors parmi les
participants vous pourrez voir passer
des équipes un peu particulière ce grâce
à des joëlettes et des bénévoles de
plusieurs associations des personnes à
mobilité réduite vont pouvoir concourir
c'est une course qui comprend les qui
comprend l'esprit des joëlettes c'est à
dire que souvent quand on s'inscrit
les organisateurs nous disent ok mais
vous vous mettez à l'arrière là les
organisateurs nous disent non devant on
a compris l'esprit c'est un partage les
personnes en situation de handicap sont
devant peuvent faire profiter à tout le
monde du fait de participer à cette
course donc c'est extraordinaire pour
nous alors il y aura plusieurs départs
qui seront donnés dans la matinée du
côté de versailles pour supporter les
marcheurs c'est à 9h45 les 10 et 20 km
s'élanceront à 10 heures et du côté de
fontenay le fleury n'est plus jeunes
participants seront à supporter dès 9h30
merci mélanie d'autres
idées de sorties dans votre émission c
dans un instant le 7-8 loisirs sur tv 78
à croissy sur seine par exemple c'est un
bond dans le temps qui vous est proposée
direction les années 70 la commune a
choisi de présenter l'époque au travers
des jouets une exposition à voir
jusqu'au 2 février
on la découvre avec vous mélanie mais
aussi avec mathilde et demi donc l'un
moi j'ai mon bateau voilà je dis que
c'est mon bateau parce que c'est vrai
que c'est ces bateaux que j'ai eu moi
dans les années soixante dix huit
exactement à noël on pourrait dire
d'eric joue ce qu'il est un grand enfant
ce passionné collectionne des jouets de
son enfance de sa passion naissent des
expositions comme les 170 s'adresse à
tout le monde
donc autant plus petit qu plus qu aux
aînés et que aux gens qui ont vécu ces
deux là en tant qu'enfant pour montrer à
leurs enfants avec quel jouet il pouvait
jouer à l'époque des années 70
immanquablement vous êtes un petit peu
près aux tripes parce que c'est les
jouets de votre enfance en tout cas pour
ce qui me concerne moi c'étaient les
petits soldats hier fixes qui sont au
premier étage
même si vous avez la lune qui au dessus
de nous donc tout un tas de choses qui
me rappelle des bons souvenirs
un voyage dans le temps et dans l'espace
à l'aube des années 70 un événement a
marqué la planète
le premier pas de l'homme sur la lune
une inspiration pour créer l'exposition
on s'est dit mais que vous avez des
enfants l'époque à quoi il joue et on a
voulu faire un focus à la fois en
briques lego sur cet événement majeur
des années 70 sur l'homme qui a marché
sur la lune mais aussi sur les jouets
qui pourraient accompagner ses enfants à
l'époque à travers leurs loisirs et
leurs plaisirs
il ne reste plus qu'à enfiler vos tenues
de spationaute et laissez vous voyagez
m
[Musique]
soit
j ouer
et puis en cette période d'halloween
venait sauver les animaux des refuges
santé et de gentils petits monstres
abandonné attendent l'amour de leur
future famille la spa les met en scène
comme ici pour les chiens et chats du
refuge de plaisir ces refuges seront
ouverts tout le week-end et aussi demain
pour le 1er novembre afin de venir
adopter ces animaux ouverture même en
nocturne jusqu'à 19h ce soir à la spa
d'orgeval et pour la fin de ce journal
justement se quitte avec ses images de
ces gentils petits monstres merci
d'avoir suivi cette édition belle soirée
à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]